Right,
no Internet.
And then it became the Internet when
we're fully formed and as an adult.
And then you got a chance to see it
and even then screwed it up and made
mistakes and got online within God viruses
on your computer and saw some stuff
he really didn't want to see
had that dial tone or you
dial in when you were gay
and then the picture would kind of come
in and little, little blips. Oh yeah.
Realize when he didn't really want to
see it anymore. I go, oh, when was,
when did you get first get a cell phone?
I got one real early. I've got a
cell phone in the 80s. Wow. Yeah.
Well it was a comedian and like 89,
I think I had a cell phone.
I had a cell phone in my car.
It was like permanently bolted down
to my car. Yeah, I got it. Those,
so I could get, the thing about
it was I could get gigs with it.
So like, uh, some people get ahold of you.
Yeah, I would like bill bloomin'. Right.
Uh, who is the owner of, um,
the Wilbur Theater in Boston.
It was owner of the comedy connection
back then. Always jokes around about it.
He was like,
you got a lot of work because you were
the only comedian with his cell phone.
Like so he could call me
up and say, hey, you know,
this guy just got a flat tire on his way
to New Hampshire. Can you do the Gig?
I'm like, fuck yeah, I'm
in. I'm, I'm there. I'm, no,
I'm already in my car cause
that's where my phone is dead.
How much did you have to pay for
that phone? I don't remember. It's,
I couldn't afford it.
No, I couldn't afford it.
I remember not being able to pay for
it after a while. Yeah, it was just,
it was a dummy. I always spent more
money than I had. I mean it's, yeah,
I've never been good with finances.
I've never been frugal.
But he's one of those things where I
realized I could get it. So I got it.
But you remember that status you'd have
to drive around if you, before that,
before you had that,
that phone in your car,
you'd have to drive what I'm looking for
a public payphone.
Oh yeah.
And you're getting a quarter's right
or you had to have a calling card.
You remember those things.
He'd have a car I would get,
I would get fake cards too. He could
buy them off people. They were like,
like counterfeit cards and they were
good for a couple of days and they'd go
under and you could buy other ones. And
then there was other things you could do.
You could take a sound device and put
it up to the phone and you could get a,
get a call with that.
Like you would put up this thing to the
voice box area and it would make noises
like Eh. Yeah. And it
would somehow or another
trick opened up the, uh, yeah,
the line, I remember that we are,
we used to before the, yeah, before
the cell phone technology hit.
And this is early days of being with
the agency. When you were overseas,
if you were in an urban setting,
you spent half your time looking
for operating payphones, right?
Some 34th world country. You're trying
to find a payphone that actually works.
Cause you've got to make some sort of,
you know,
call related to whatever
operation you're engaged in.
And the kids, the kids, the kids today
and the agency, you don't understand that,
you know, cause they've all got great
technology and mobile communications.
But uh, yeah, in the old days it was,
it didn't, it didn't work that way.
There's people that even knew what a phone
booth is. No, I, yeah, exactly. I take,
they'd say like about fights.
That's like a common expression.
These two could have fought in the phone.
Both that could've fought fight.
And I can't even say it could
a fight in a phone booth.
But today you say fight in
a phone booth and people go,
why don't just say they got a
fight on her fucking, you know,
something else that doesn't exist
anymore. A wine barrel. This London,
you're London now and you know
that those iconic red phone booth,
you haven't met a phone. It, there's
a I'm work. What are they now?
You just keep getting them up.
Yeah, I think they kept him update.
You could probably find one occasionally.
It's got a phone in it,
but it wasn't that long ago.
I remember they actually had
functioning phones in there.
You would go outside any
seven 11 or whatever.
And they were doing a bank of payphones.
I actually stopped and took
a picture I was having,
I forget where the hell are we nowhere
pulled into a gas station. It was,
I was pulling out after, oddly
enough, getting gas and uh,
I looked over to the side and there
was a pay phone against the wall.
And then now that the receiver
was just dangling on the ground,
but I literally stopped,
got out and took a picture of it
so I could show my kids, you know,
we used to make calls on these things.
This is how it worked.
I remember when there was no answering
machines. You remember that? Yeah. Yeah.
And the first answer machine and whoever
your buddy was at got the answering
machine first. You thought, man,
that's the deal. That's so posh.
And I remember we got an answering
machine where you could call it,
and then when the dial tone went on,
you would punch in a code and you could
listen to your messages and you weren't
even home.
You could retrieve those messages crazy.
You could call it of the car to your
answering machine. Pick it. There's a,
there's a funny, yeah. Okay. Maybe you
shouldn't, I guess I, what do I know?
But you should never start a story
out by saying there's a funny story.
There's this story that
when Lyndon Johnson was a,
was a precedent and not, not
present, I take that back.
He was in the Senate and it was another
guy, Dirksen. It was a famous senator.
And so Johnson was,
uh, uh, one day he was,
he was driving, Dirksen gets this
call, I think I got their guy, right?
It gets a call from Johnson and they're
talking and Johnson and say, wow,
I got to talk to you about this thing.
He says, Whoa, Whoa, hold on. Oh,
hold on a second. He
says, I gotta, you know,
we're just pulling up outside
the building. I got to get out.
I'll call you when I get to my
office and says, what are you,
where are you calling me now? And he
goes, well, I got a phone in my car.
And so Dirksen hangs up and meet is
this, I gotta get one of those. So he,
this, as the story goes, he pulled
some strings there in the Senate,
got somebody to put a phone in his car,
right?
And so then he calls Johnson and he says,
uh,
Lyndon just calling your from from my car.
And Johnson says,
ah, that's, that's, that's
great. Hold on a second.
I got a call coming in on the other line.
Thanks up on him.
So, Eh, yeah. Yeah. Whether it's true
or not, it's an apocryphal story.
Phones in their car back then. Yeah.
Well, you know, if you're a senator,
what year did they invent? Carphone's? Uh,
probably the year you got
one. No, I don't, I have no
idea when they infected ones.
But you know, uh, Jamie, we
should look in 1946 1946 what,
what? Yeah, yeah. Wait a minute.
1946 imagine will come up.
Pimp you had to be in 1969 to
pull up and like a 69 corvette.
The fucking phone in your car or
Lincoln town car. Whoa. This is what it,
that's like a car phone is a mobile
phone device specifically designed to be
fitted in automobile. That's what we
should call him back then. Car phones.
Remember service originated with the
bell system and was first used in Saint
Louis.
June 17th,
1946 before the fucking end of
the war, right? Yeah. No, no, no.
That was after the end of
the war. End. 45 okay. Yeah.
So a year after the World War II,
that's an incredible phone in their car.
And more importantly, why,
why St Louis? What was,
what the hell is going on in St Louis? It,
that's the site of the first car phone.
Wow.
It was a radio enthusiasts who had the
foresight to invent the annoying habit of
talk on the phone while in the car.
So basically worked on the radio and it
would somehow or another connect to a
regular phone lines. Is that what
it worked? Uh, Jesus Christ. Yeah.
This is way beyond my apple watch rounds
had this look Johnson had it when he
was in the Senate. Yep. Yeah.
So and that would have been,
yeah. What's that? That's,
that would have been like 15 years after
this happened or, or 14 years after.
After they invented it in Saint Louis.
But, but yeah, I remember when they,
you know, the mobile phone
then was that big case do that.
We carry around and give it to get out
of your car set out out on your car and
then it started getting
too big fucking thing.
You throw over your shoulder a big handle.
I've got a big box at home full of all
the old phones that I've had over the
years and it's like if I could
ever get myself organized,
I would turn it into some sort of wall
art installation cause it's cell phones
through the years at least
covering the past three decades.
It's certainly interesting.
What do you got there at Jamie first
developed in 1920 mobile wireless
transmission device.
Send and receive messages in the
1920s phone like in 19 and 20 Jesus,
that guy behind him as the boss,
you can tell he's, he's listening.
He's the guy in charge, man. Wow.
Yeah.
I think that would be a great idea to
show kids today that I'm that old brick
phone from Wall Street.
Fantastic to the,
was it called the star Tech
Startac those were the bag I saw.
Somebody's still using one of those the
other day. Yeah, the little flip flops.
A little flip phone with the little was
kinda would come out. Yeah. To be fair,
he dead.
He had a Dork knob startac
there was a sweet phone.
I had one of those. I was like, oh baby.
It was like, like Star Trek, right?
You were like Captain
Kirk with that thing.
You flip it open and you're talking about
maybe you can get an extra fat battery
for it. Although that didn't set so
well in your suit coat. It's terrible.
Those fat batteries,
but if you didn't have a fat battery,
you can make a call for four minutes.
Battery Technology was terrible back
there. That waterway fallen, by the way,
has an excellent battle.
It's got a great battery amp
battery that battery is doing.
It's sucking all the information out
of your system and you got it. Yeah,
but sweet, sweet signal that you get
so long while it does that. It is true.
It is true. Go out there kids,
get yourself a Huawei bat phone,
amazing cameras.
They have a 40 megapixel camera in one.
They make all sorts of white goods too,
you know,
like washers and dryers and
refrigerators and those.
They're putting all that stuff in our
homes. Yes, it is. Yes, it, so I wouldn't,
I wouldn't engage in any
shenanigans in my kitchen.